how you guys doing
what's up steve how you doing man i am
talking about an awesome show this is a
[ __ ] good day
welcome it's really that simple so a
bunch of questions i'm going to start
with i think
probably the most important one um when
did you guys know billy joel was joining
the cast
i remember reading it but i you know
yeah i didn't get the chance
billy joel does play a big part of
season two from what i've seen
yeah was it in the script did eric tell
you by the way you should probably
listen to some billy joel
no no never mentioned it to us i feel
like that was a conversation between he
and uh
and jack yeah yeah yeah yeah i feel like
that was a thing between them for sure
but for me
now it was a nice pleasant surprise uh
one of the things about this season is
um eric told me that you guys had
a longer shooting schedule in the first
season you had a certain amount of days
but in season two you had more
can you sort of talk about what those
added days was able to add to what you
were able to put on
screen in season two oh man
i think what we discovered in season one
is that we needed those days just so
that we had the
you know like the cushion to to play
around like a lot of the best moments in
this show are
found after we've kind of just got the
straight and narrow done
you know um chase i've heard you talk
about the scene with the gills quite a
few times
you say you had just enough time to play
around with that and try some things and
then
yeah the mash-up is what made that
moment so great
and that was a lot of what we discovered
in season one it was like dang if we had
another
few hours per scene then we'd be able to
find those moments that
we didn't really know that we'd be
looking for and in season two we we
finally had that
and in season three from from what i
hear we're gonna have even more of that
they've already added like three days
per episode
um just just so that we we you know
we're able to
to to find those moments because that's
honestly where the show
lives it lives in that kind of my one
example was this
this season uh i'm freaking episode two
or three but the
stuff with me in the gills by myself and
uh
yeah you know we it was it was second
unit which was great and and because we
had
i just had so much time to do it to get
it right we had like six seven hours and
it was just
you know there was another scene before
or after breathing down our neck to try
and make the make
the thing happen so it was it was a nice
freedom
um in that regard yeah as i understand
it they're adding a few more on to next
season as well so it's a big show
there's tons of stuff going on
everyone's kind of on their own path
and uh yeah one of the things that i
love about the show and i'm sure you
guys also love it is that every episode
has a what the [ __ ] moment
something that you sorry for the
language but something that you know you
are not
expecting comes out of left field leaves
you with you know
shell-shocked jaw on the ground what is
it like reading that on the page
and how much are you being told in
advance before you see the script
you won't believe what's coming in
episode three and it's this uh
if there's some type of preparation that
needs to be done then we'll get a little
bit of uh you know some advanced
knowledge but for the most part
we don't learn anything until we get the
script and then
as we're kind of reading through there's
always that moment of hold on wait a
minute i know i didn't just see what i
think i saw
backtrack a couple pages and then
re-read to make sure that i'm not
you know that i didn't miss something
and that happened more in season two
than
ever before like in my entire career
it's just
you know i think every episode like you
said
has those moments and for me i was
trying to place them in my mind of like
how do they make sense like where are
they going with this
that's the thing that i i think i'm most
excited about for season two is that you
know on september 4th you're getting
three episodes but then you have to wait
a week
for each episode after that and that
gives you
the time to to let your brain wonder the
way like ours do when we're waiting for
scripts you know like where where is
this going like what's happening right
now
um why did this happen and how is that
going to fit into this next piece and
that was the most exciting thing about
waiting for those scripts for me at
least
was just thinking about it over the you
know the course of a week a week and a
half before we got the next script
because
man they just you know they came from
way left field
with every single episode we're very
thankful for that that's one of my
favorite parts about being on this show
really yeah i mean the only story i have
from from that is is from the first
season and like the eighth and the f
in the finale crippy did sort of email
me or text me or something
kind of hey man the script's coming out
later like tomorrow
just for warning there's there's
something in there about you
you know shaving your head like are you
cool with doing that you know i was kind
of like yeah man that actually sounds
great you know i get on camera and
i read it and it actually had me shaving
like my
arms and my eyebrows and i kind of i
shot them back i'm like
but i'm good with everything i i ain't
shaving my eyebrows
[Laughter]
they might not grow back we can do
prosthetics if you want i don't think we
need it i think the head shavings enough
anyway he was just happy that i was
willing to do the head so
yeah no i actually i i have your back on
that one i also agree
with i mean seriously if it might not
grow back that's a real thing
you know i'm like i i think we're good
with just the head you know
um making the first season of any show
you learn a lot
um in terms of what you're able to
accomplish during that week what it
takes to make it just all
you know all the stuff that goes on
behind the scenes what did you guys take
from the first season
and applied to season two um i'm very
i'm curious if you learned anything
you know what i mean man we learned so
much we learned one a lot about the
costumes
uh you know functionality of the
costumes had to be reworked
um because i think they looked the best
when we first started season one
that was when they were like the
prettiest but there was a lot of things
that just needed to be worked through so
that
a train could run or you know things
like
that or so that home learner could could
flex and move and
you know there was just a lot of uh a
lot of application that needed to be
worked through but also
it was a matter of the dynamic between
each other
you know we the first season is always
is always different than the rest of the
show because we're learning each other
as as actors as people and you know
we're learning
eric kripke's style and the things that
he's gonna want to see
and um it's it's a lot like this show
has
so many components involved there's so
many cast members and things like that
it just takes some time to
really get enveloped in the show and i
think in the first season we were
kind of just learning how this goes and
then
in the second season we were a little
bit better but we still had a lot to
learn
and uh this third season i can't wait to
see where we're going because now we're
ready to knock it out of the park
and um it's hard to believe that you
know the first season was
received so well when we were still
figuring out so much
so uh the sky is the limit from here
probably the main thing i sort of took
away from season one or watching season
one
was that i was like i was kind of uh you
know i sort of you forget doing certain
takes or doing certain things but i
realized i'm like wow they did use that
one crazy take in that one time and i
want to do more of that you know next
year
whatever so i really you know didn't
want to shy away from playing it safe
like i really i'm like okay they like
you know these kind of wild directions
the one take with like yo do what you
want to do like really take that for
yourself so i kind of
that was one thing i kind of remember
going into season two being like i
definitely want to
do more try more of that because they
might you know they might use it
no i'm i just have to agree with with
chase that fearlessness they kind of
instill that in you you know where you
feel like you can show up on set
and try whatever you want and somehow it
will probably end up in this show
yeah yeah that's a good feeling that's a
really good feeling to have
yeah man uh last comic-con i believe i
spoke to you guys
um when those i remember yeah that what
the show was i'd seen some episodes it
hadn't really come out
i was [ __ ] blown away by it and then
you were filming season two
what was it like to leave comic-con
after that sort of reception
and go back to to continue filming and
at that point the show comes out
and and you're i'm curious what is it
like filming on location with the
suits when now people know what this
show is
oh man i thought it was awesome i mean
yeah it's just i mean comic con in
general was fun
like that was such a blast because that
was my first time
i'm not sure if it was yours jesse or
not but that was just a fun moment to
have with like the whole cast
kripke in san diego with you guys you
know having their first interactions
with it
celebrating kind of partying it up and
then it coming out like july 26th that
was i just thought that was awesome so
yeah man it was incredible going back to
to work
after having that kind of like
affirmation was
unlike anything that's ever happened
before usually you're done with
something before
it reaches that you know before it
reaches the masses like that
and um we kind of we were really nervous
or at least i was i was really nervous
going down to comic con you just don't
know how things are going to be
you know you know maybe your panel might
be empty because no one knows the show
but it was
packed and people were already kind of
in love with the idea of the show
then the show came out and and then
we're back back to work
and now all of a sudden the crew and
people around the town are kind of
talking about the show already um while
we're in the in the middle of production
it just felt good you know it felt so
good like my alarm would wake up to go
to work and it's just like
i i have the confirmation that people
are loving this as much as i
am and um it just it
and that's another component that
instills that fearlessness in you now
you feel like
i can do what i want i'm scared
[Laughter]
it is a good feeling though i know what
you're talking about it is yeah
yeah i already got to stop i'm just
going to say i thought the first three
episodes of season two were fantastic
i cannot wait to see where it goes you
guys have fun speed dating the rest of
the day